yes my name is Tim I've come over from
Cardiff University at the moment I'm in
the final year of PhD where I've been
trying to see if we can do any patent
trying to find any pattern matching
within the field of schizophrenia
genomics ok so just I'm going to start
this talk off with a quick personal
requests because the usual audience when
I'm giving talks are experts in biology
psychiatry and very few of them have
little if not no experience of machine
learning or coding so for any points
anyone is feeling like this during my
talk you know please you know if there's
any problems please let me know if it's
really bad maybe let me know outside so
it's not on camera and I can eat
biscuits thank you right so just I
really give a very quick background into
schizophrenia and it's genetics it's a
debilitating psychiatric condition that
has a lifetime prevalence rate of about
0.7 to 1% of the population now it's
associated with a load of a whole
variety of different symptoms some of
which are quite commonly known amongst
the general population but you also have
those that are not so well known often
those coming under this negative
symptoms that we have here so I found
this on the internet the other week and
I think it's quite an interesting image
because when I'm talking to the
clinicians that work in my department
you realize how awful this disorder is
for people because they really are
trapped inside torment within their own
minds and for some of them it's as if
they can't get out of their own
nightmares and it's very easy for me to
sit down you know I get bogged down by
looking at numbers and trying to find
pattern I just really easy to forget
actually what we're trying to do which
is to get rid of people going through
things like this so as for the genetics
it's um what makes the what makes the
genetics of schizophrenia interesting
but also difficult is that you don't
have like a single tag there's no single
biomarker or mutation that you can have
that will say this will give you
schizophrenia if you contrast that would
say something like Huntington's disease
but what instead is that you have these
small sort of cumulative contributions
from all over the genome and these are
often very common mutation
is that all of us here we'll have some
of the mutations but it's a case of
there's certain patterns that you can
have but again won't determine whether
you'll get it but they can increase your
probability of getting it so that's what
makes this really quite interesting to
research so if we look at the sort of
mutations that I deal excuse me that I
deal with are these common mutations
that we call snips so just to give an
example here this is where cuz for on
the most part we all of our DNA we share
a lot of our DNA we share a lot of DNA
with our closest ancestors or the
primates and I think it's something like
two-thirds of our DNA we share with a
banana so there's a you know there's a
lot that we that we have in common but
there are these particular places where
they've spotted these single nucleotide
base changes in the genome as we've got
an example in this diagram here where
for that section of DNA it's all the
same apart from that one point now well
the diagram here shows is that there's 3
different times that this at this point
on the most part what we're looking at
is that there's normally one or the
other and a little section of DNA that
has these mutations is what we refer to
as an allele so this is a tri allelic
mutation but for the most part two by
allele it that we're looking at as an
example here of one of the mutations
that has been found to be associated
with schizophrenia on chromosome 1 so
just to point out that because we have
double-stranded DNA you can either have
none of these mutations one of these
mutations or if you get on both of these
strands then you have two of these
mutations so that will be used in the
calculations later so one of the tools
in the armory in psychiatric genetics is
a genome-wide Association test and what
this does is it looks at the
distribution of the major alleles so
these are the those base pairs that are
more commonly seen in the population
with the minor alleles across cases and
controls so you get to build my two
contingency table for each mutation and
then what you do is you calculate an
odds ratio from this the distribution
amongst the cases of controls and you
can also get a p-value from a
chi-squared test now when we enter into
these things there are millions of these
mutations that get put in so there is
need of multiple
Harrison correction you don't need to do
it for every single one because there is
belief that there are a million
independent sections of the genome and
when I say independent what I mean is
the the crossover recombination that
happens during reproduction between your
chromosomes there are certain
breakpoints on these and the assumption
is that this results in a million sort
of sections of the genome so well
effectively doing a million independent
tests so what they do is they correct
for this with a bond for any correction
factor of a million which takes a
threshold value down to P times which
equals five times ten to the minus eight
just a quick note that if you're dealing
with ratio data which is distributed
about one it's often nice to take the
logarithm of it because the the odds
ratio is not evenly distributed about
one if you take the logarithm that makes
it evenly distributed about zero so
that's what we put into the calculation
so this slide has been going around
pretty much every single psychiatric
genetics conference it was a paper that
was a bit of a name drop for nature
there so that made it to nature and what
they did was an enormous consortium
study of schizophrenia sufferers from
labs all over the world of which Cardiff
was one and what they do is they did
this took all of these and they looked
at all the different mutations and what
they found was that there were 128 of
these snips that were significantly
associated with schizophrenia at this
stringent level and what we're seeing
here is something called a Manhattan
plot for self explanatory reasons and
what we've got is you take the negative
log 10 of the p-value because often
these p-values are very crammed very
close to zero so you take the negative
log 10 of it which stretches it out so
that you can see the differences more
clearly and what you see is anything
that gets past this red line meets that
criteria so just a point we're
interested in those that are the little
diamonds at the top the green ones
they've also sort of met the criteria
but they're within these these chunks of
genome that I was talking about so
basically if you've got one of those
you've got the diamond one and it's the
diamond ones that were interested in so
the aim of my study was I was looking at
our subsection actually some of them
that were that were genotyped at Cardiff
and these are people
treatment resistance gets free now first
of all to get a smaller sample and
secondly to see if those something we
could drill down about these particular
sufferers is this a sort of sub
phenotype within schizophrenia and these
are often some of the most you know from
the clinicians tell me these are people
that really suffer from the disorder
they've been on medication that has
failed for at least two years I believe
and they're receiving this drug it's
this sort of drug of last resort called
clozapine there is an unequal balance of
cases and controls but I'll show how
scikit-learn
really nicely deals with that later so
what I do is I enter the number of the
minor allele counts I enter that into
the support vector machine model I
compare it with the traditional method
that's used in the field which is to
create a polygenic score so just quickly
go over that what they do is they take
these counts zero one or two take them
for all the mutations multiply that
weight it by the log odds ratio that
they've got from the G was now
importantly that has got to be a GU as
with these individuals removed and
they've done that that's fine because
you can't use their case control status
to make a metric which is then in turn
use to predict their case control status
so that has been covered by the M by the
consortium group so you get with that
you get a sort of a weighted allele
counts for these people and you take the
mean of it and that gives you a single
risk score per person which they call
the polygenic score and you can then
look at this with logistic regression to
see if you can predict case control
status they said it is its predictive
accuracy is very weak it cannot be used
for prediction in schizophrenia in fact
because of the low numbers of people
that suffer from schizophrenia if you
want a classification model just point
at someone and say you haven't got
schizophrenia because in that case
you're gonna be right 99 percent of the
time and maybe accuracy this is no way
near to that so there's obviously there
is room for people to try and improve on
it which is why I've been working on in
this field I've been using the support
vector machines because what they does
if you're taking a sort of a sum of all
of these features like the polygenic
score does it doesn't take into account
any nonlinear effects that could have
been happening so that's why I've used
linear and nonlinear kernels for the
support vector machine so if anyone's
not familiar with it's got a very very
quick recap of what they're trying to do
this is a simple to feature model here
so what we've got if you've got these
two different classes and a support
vector machine is trying to find the
optimum decision boundary between them
this is all using and this is all like
developed from pictures that on site get
loans documentation which is as good as
their software so this is the optimal
hyperplane what does it mean by optimum
what it's doing is its maximizing the
distance between these dotted lines and
it's sold by quite a it's a non trivial
quadratic programming tool that does
this but interestingly what it does is
it uses these that I say if you can see
it some of them that are closed that are
actually on the dotted line
they're circled and they're referred to
as the support vectors so it's the
comparisons between these points they
get used to make this hyperplane so when
you're building these models you'll hear
about parameter tuning that takes place
and this is an example of why if you've
got a point here which it could have
been measured correctly you know is it
blue but it looks as if it really should
be okay can everyone see this is it
clear
it looks as if it really should belong
in the other group so you can set this
cost parameter called
C now you can say no get it right and
it'll do something like this so it will
do what you're telling it to but a
better approach might be to do something
like this which means that you're
letting this one go you're saying okay
fine let that one go but this model
we've got a nice large margin back this
will probably hopefully be more
generalizable to new data which is the
whole point of building these models and
this also shows that a support vector
machine is capable of building a soft
margin classifier it doesn't need to get
everything right so it can solve
problems that aren't completely linearly
separable that being said there are
cases where it's really not going to
work and this is sort of a variant of a
classic example called the exclusive-or
example where if you've got high values
in one or the other feature then you'll
get the disorder but if you've got none
or you've got both then you're not going
to have it so you could in maybe one of
them cancels the other way out for
example bit of a toy example but here we
go
any attempt at a linear boundary it's
just not going to work with this so what
we do is we do these cookies use a
kernel function and that's essentially
it looks at the relationship between the
support vectors in a different way and
we get this we're now back to 100
and accuracy and you might hear that
people say oh this problem is not
linearly separable in two dimensions but
it's Lily separable in a higher
dimension and the way I visualize this
is it works something like that so now
if you're plotting the points rather
than plotting those points that were in
orange onto a flat surface they're now
actually effectively they're gonna
appear at the top of these mountains so
now when you if they're now there you
can then put a linear plane through them
and you've got your linear separability
back okay so the next thing about
Moschino is you got it the half the
battle is finding out what exactly
you're gonna put into these models now I
could use the weighted batter just a web
how I'm visualizing when people say if
you take it into higher dimensions
because sometimes if you're talking
about many many dimensions you can't
visualize it but that one you can it was
purely a visualization tool for it so
just going back to what I was going to
enter into these put into these models I
was thinking about entering the way to
the Lil counts like the polygenic school
has because that provides some important
information if you've got a mutation
that seemed more in controls it's going
to have a positive value and then
negative value for the opposite if it
seemed more encases but the problem here
is that these these are allele counts
are sparse they have to they have zero
values because remember you could have
none of these mutations and this really
concerned me with the pollak the
polynomial and there's an example here
of a quadratic kernel so this is a
polynomial with a degree two because
what we're really interested in is the
last term in that equation which is an
interaction term now if anything you're
entering in here is a zero it's gonna
it's gonna knock that interaction to it
you're not going to be measuring what
you what you want the RBF kernel is not
so susceptible to this but the only way
to really check is to do a quick example
so I do an explicit XOR example int in
here I build the targets sorry I build
the inputs and I build the targets as
you can see here imagine that you have a
sample per row if they've got one or the
other then
they've got the disorder in the targets
not for the other two and then you would
never do this actually machine in but I
use the same model to predict the same
inputs and just see how it deals with
them and it's done like this now we're
not expecting the linear one to get it
right it can't the RBF does fine as I
thought but the concern here the
polynomial one is not getting it so the
alternative tonight is let's scale the
inputs and what you do by it is scaling
them very easily in scikit-learn what
you then do is you scale it so that for
each feature you have a mean of 0 and a
variance of 1 and in fact what it's done
here is it's swapped out the zeros for a
minus 1 if we do that run it through and
both of the nonlinear kernels are
performing as we would expect them to so
that made me decide I'm going to use
scaled features I'm not going to allow
the zeros to go into it so now I've
decided on the features we now need to
talk about the parameter search and this
is where I it really made my life easier
I'll go on to show why because from some
initial trials I found that it was the
lower values of C and this other one
gamma which gets used for the nonlinear
kernels so is the lower value so what
you can do is rather than giving
explicit values in a grid search that
you want to look through you can give
scikit-learn probability distributions
so you say sample some points from this
probability distribution carry out four
fold cross validation is everyone clear
with cross validation how you you test
on you leave you hold some data out okay
so anyway so what you do is you pick
some parameters from the from these
distributions four fold cross validation
get the best score and then you keep
iterating that many times until you get
what you think is the best combination
of parameters sounds complicated it is
this easy in scikit-learn way after you
import some of the models loading your
information and what you do you build
the CV model of their cross validation
model build the support vector machine
the scaling has to be done in a cross
validation model as well you have to see
you have to do that in a pipeline
scaling so rather than scaling at all
because then the test information would
have information on the scaling from the
training data what you do is you find
out the mean and the variance of the
training data and then you apply that to
the test data for that's done very
easily with this pipeline feature then
you build the probability distributions
and then you run it through this
model here this randomized search CV and
it does everything for you I actually
wrote in to a forum about this someone
said use this and it's that easy and I
was very happy about that
so just to show how well this has been
thought out is really made my life so
much easier so that's gone on to some
results
spoiler alert oh sorry there's one thing
I meant I forgot to point out here as
well this end jobs equals minus one this
is a really nice feature because it uses
the job Lib library which a temple with
a little bit but I'm more leave their
implementation to it what that says is
use all the CPUs available so when I
send this off to a cluster I can send it
off to a node that's got sixteen CPU
cores I can do that at night and then I
bet it's all done then by the next
morning so it really is nice you can
just say use all the resources that
you've got and is that simple to do it
the results so ultimately what I was
hoping when I start with PhD because you
all think you're gonna solve science no
unfortunately we can't and what I've
also got here is I was going to say one
small thing here this class y equals
balanced that's the thing that deals
with the imbalance between the classes
by applying a different cost function to
each of them so anyway back to this
welder than the pointer I had some extra
data here that was actually done on a
different genotyping chip I initially
kept it out for completely separate test
data it was poor performing similarly so
I entered it in as well
now unfortunately the support vector
machines are not doing as well as this
polynomials this polygenic score and the
even valued polynomial kernels are
completely bombing if I've got some time
I'll show that I've done some
simulations to find out why is this
happening this is indicative of main
effects telling the whole story if I've
got time I'll show that but again even
when I've added these extra sample
points is not really improving on the
score however story's a little bit
different with this one again I'm not
solving schizophrenia but the polygenic
score is not improving at all when I add
any of the extra features and what the
views tears rather than just use those
do you has significant snips I've
relaxed the threshold and I've taken it
down to around 5,000 the reason it's
4,998 was because there was a nice
p-value cutoff I could use here
and I said right I wanted 5,000 maximum
because after you've stripped the
training sample down I still wanted more
samples and features that I was using
that was around 5,000 so I say let in
all of those sub-threshold snips
and what we're seeing here is again
right
yeah the polygenic score is doing the
best this is the actual value that they
got from that nature paper so I'm
replicating that but here right some of
the nonlinear kernels are performing a
bit better the reason I'm using a mouse
I did have a pointer but it doesn't work
on these screens so that's why I'm doing
this and also the all the support vector
machines are now benefiting considerably
from this extra data by the way the
metric is the receiver operating
characteristic is everyone familiar with
how that works we're okay what it is is
what you do is imagine if you were to
relax the boundaries of it so if you
were to move the support vector machine
boundary you do is you move it and you
look at the trade-off between false
positives and true positives as you move
it so if it's completely chance if it
there randomly distributed then you'll
get a value of 0.5 one is perfect
classification so 0.65 don't think
that's active that's still 0.7 is still
pretty bad so that's reason why we're
trying to improve on these things so the
question is can we if we you know really
boost more samples can we get more
information coming into this now I don't
know that's an open-ended question
because it could be the case that
asymptotes around 0.7 nothing nothing
that we enter into it is going to be
improved but the alternative to that is
are we going to start still see that
with more and more people these are
going to creep up the nonlinear kernels
are going to do better suggest that
there are interactions that we don't
know it's an open-ended question with
that but I still thought well my
supervisor found this quite exciting and
we're talking about it next week so the
next thing is can we get because that's
how that's putting a lot of features
into the model that's 5,000 feet nearly
5,000 features ago and these take a long
time trying there's only way that we can
get the signal from across the genome
but reduce the dimensionality in such a
way and yes we can and this aware pandas
really comes into its own because what I
was doing was putting these mutations in
sort of functional groups that they come
together and the genes are the areas
within the gene
that code proteins and they also have
been from experiments from experiments
these are the people that work in lamps
with blue gloves and I never go anywhere
near them well then but I don't not when
they're working cuz I've tried it and
it's not really not for me there's
nothing wrong with them but anyway they
found that they there are certain genes
are related in these functional sort of
categories and by looking at the
different databases where they show the
location of these genes the gene sets
and the location of the mutations that
were using there's really nice database
functionality within pandas that you can
prepare a data frame this is an example
data frame that I've got here the values
are actually I don't whether you can
read the values because these screens
are very small but I've had to make them
up because it's all confidential data
I've only got it for two samples here so
what you would have is you'd have some
you know seven thousand odd columns for
the samples but what's so good is that
once you've got this this is all the
mutations mapped to all of their genes
all of their gene sets and what we've
got here are these sort of classes of
gene sets there's six of those pandas
does it in three lines you just use a
group by function out just as you would
in in SQL and you just get the mean
value I drop the the reason why drop
duplicates is because you had can have
gene regions that crossover with each
other
so I eliminate that and then you just
group by on the gene set and take the
mean and that that left me with a
hundred and thirty three features
capturing it didn't capture those
mutations that fell in non-coding
regions but it was still you know still
way of looking at how these are
performing then we can enter these into
the model some results I focused on at
this point using the linear model the
reason being is as actually in showed in
his previous talk you can get
information from the coefficients that
are assigned to the features because in
a support vector machine it's actually
describing a vector that's orthogonal to
the decision plane so when you project
one tooth on to the other if you to
protect a new feature on to that vector
if it crosses the decision plane it
changes class if not then it doesn't so
you can interpret these things they're
not black box once you stick a kernel on
it it does become more black box so what
I did here I also used the multiple
regression feature within scikit-learn
and I was using this linear SVC it's a
slightly different
some ization algorithm that they use
it's faster it can only be used for
linear kernels but you can also apply
this last su penalty onto it which means
that if a feature is really considered
to be doing nothing for the model this
can now assign it a value of zero if
needs be again it would be really nice
wouldn't it are we improving on
apologetic score no science but but we
can get you know with the coefficient we
can get some interesting information out
of this and when I got this out I was
quite happy about this not immediately I
was like oh that's interesting read
about it and I oh this is really
interesting because these things at the
top F MRP that describes a gene set
called fragile ment are of fragile X
mental retardation protein and what this
is it's a they're targets of this
protein this protein binds onto the
product of the DNA called RNA from these
genes that are listed here and it
transports these these RNA from the
nucleus of the cell to the synaptic of
the cell so it has also other lab work
has shown that it's implicated in
schizophrenia so I then also used some
other software called this Magma
software which is what's called gene set
Association analysis and what that did
that found that this set at the top was
the only one that was significantly
associated with it so I'm very happy to
say that the support vector machines
were basically singing from the same
song sheet as other software to ways to
look at about this I was quite happy
saying well you know it's making sense
of course there's the attitude that one
of my supervisor said which was to come
up to me and go kind of means there's no
real point in doing what you've been
doing then you can just use this other
software so yeah there's two ways of
looking at I'm going to go with my way
just so that it's still obvious because
I've got to write something up but of
course we can go on from this because
what magma can't do is it can't look for
these nonlinear effects if we use the
kernel functions are we going to show
some interactions is this going to be
really nice
no it's also not going to be I mean you
can't improve on this polygenic school
thing here I mean but again there's no
it's not say that it's not worth doing
maybe there's more information that we
need to combine into this and I remember
when I started my PhD someone said to me
don't worry about trying to solve too
much what you're doing is you're wanting
to add a grain of sand to the beach that
is human knowledge and this this could
have been my grain of sand at that been
there but instead as as usual I found
this surfing it's a circling around
social media the other week and it's
cited sums it up really it sums it up so
found some I'm glad that it's supporting
other software we haven't found any
nonlinear effects
unfortunately we might be able to see
more if we have some more samples that's
what we always say but we know we'll
we'll see from that so in conclusion the
support vector machines I'm 40 didn't
improve on the performance there might
be some interactions with the
sub-threshold snips but again the gene
set analysis did show it supported
current research and other techniques
now how am i doing for time okay right
because what I wanted to do was because
we got these strange if we go back to
the this pattern that we're seeing I was
interested you know what's causing this
how can these are bombing so badly so I
wrote like I'm gonna show some code here
so I'm a little bit nervous about this
don't scrutinize it too much so what
I've got here if anyone can it's very
small on these screens can people can
you see it so what I did here what I
wanted to do was basically say okay if
we don't use the phenotype that is the
case of control status if instead I I
make it because I can say let's make it
from the main effects or let's introduce
interactions into the model and then see
if we know they're there because we've
made them can the models find them
because we're really nice is the thing
that you're thinking these things can
find can indeed they find them that was
why I wanted to do this so I made this
um this so just wrote this quick script
here that takes you take the inputs you
put it into the model and I I do choose
to scale them so you have the scaled
input values and this is just to make a
phenotype this and there's no machine
learning taking place here
and then what I do I can say how many of
the features do we want to use default
is all of them now importantly how many
interactions because what we the sort of
thing we're looking for is this are
they're a subsection of these mutations
that might be there their effect
together is like it's more than the sum
of their parts so we've got a nonlinear
effect so I say only take 10% of them
make pairwise interactions this
penetrance value want to be the best
value that the best term to use here but
what it means is if you meet the
criteria for the main effects this is
your probability of having a phenotype
if the interactions make it so I wanted
this to be higher because you want a
strong effect so these interactions
coming in and you can also you can
additionally weight them so because it
performs a weighted average on these
importantly with this is if you set the
main weight or the interaction weight to
zero what you can say is only consider
main effects or only consider
interaction and so on and so forth do
some checks are what I'm putting in and
then I use this to basically make this
phenotype which is then returned at the
base here anything yes and it's really
not you know some of the functionality
within numpy so we all need to thank
Travis and he will get to see him talk
in a few days because it's so it makes
it so easy that you can do a weighted
average to get these results and it runs
super quick as well and then sorry this
is the thing that basically drives that
you enter in the values that you want
and then you build that this is all very
much along the same lines as what I was
doing in here before and these are some
of the results we get with the default
that we have where you've got 10% of the
interaction 10% of the features having a
fairly strong effect on the performance
this polygenic so I'm not too sure how
to interpret this one because I made it
from the scaled allele counts rather
than the actual weight at a tell count
so take that one with a pinch of salt
but what was nice to see is that the
nonlinear ones are behaving as we would
expect them to have behave it's
performing better than the linear in
this case don't read into this too much
because it was just a quick way of
making some phenotypes with this when I
set the interaction the effect of the
interactions to be far lower
I didn't weight them in too
additionally and I kept a very similar
stat penetrance level on them and what
bigot we're beginning to see here are
similar patterns to what we got in the
real data where the even polynomial
kernel start dropping out and with this
one I've set the interaction weight to
be zero so it's only going on main
effects and then why was puzzle is why
those polynomial even degrees really not
performing and when you make a feature
purely based on main effects or just
sorry just to say how how I decide
whether it is or not what I do is if
you've got all the values for the main
effects I take the I take the value for
the row sorry I should have mentioned
this that's done here if I got all of
the main conditions I take the value of
the rows which is an individual score
and if that score is greater than the
global mean I say yes they meet that
criteria and if it's below it then they
don't meet that criteria combine those
two probabilities from the main effects
and the interactions just to see it's it
was just a way of trying to invent you
know put something there and see if the
machine learning could find it and as I
suspected these were you know if you
main effects only you do see a dropout
for the even kernels one thing that I
don't if anyone can knows about this and
can help me with this because one thing
I'd if I was really quite puzzled out
was when I set the value to be three so
looking at three-way interactions
suddenly the linear has popped back into
into life again the Pollard the
polygenic score hasn't but this linear
value has jumped up again so if anyone
knows why I'm puzzled by that but I
would appreciate some help with that so
if we go back to my talk I think that's
it now so thank you again sums up my PhD
thank you ever so much for listening and
thanks to my soup
the slack channel is asked about slides
whether you have rightly I need to
unease funny about them because this is
the first time I've ever used an eye
Python notebook
they are HTML slides I tried to sort of
save them to be and I were talking about
this yesterday I tried to save them to
PDF when I find out how to do it and yes
I'm I'll make them available oh well so
once I find out yes I'll go through the
channels and it's all it's all locally
so yeah I can yeah I can see if I can't
do that can I told you about that
afterwards in finance so okay okay I'm
Katie
yep that's fine
yes they are one of the reasons is so if
anyone a copy number variant what that
is because I'm looking at just a single
mutation change on a point of DNA what
you can have is that you can have
sections of DNA which for some
individuals can actually be deleted
completely or you can have sections
where it's just repeated and you can
have many many repeated these a good
example can be a deletion on chromosome
22 is I mean if you have that you've got
a very strong chance of getting
schizophrenia but it's all there also
comorbid with other disorders so that
one is is associated with severe
intellectual disability but to go back
the reason why I'm not using them is yes
they've got a strong effect size on
whether you get it but such a tiny
proportion of schizophrenia sufferers
will actually have these mutations and
the problem is that when you're using
machine learning what you look what what
you're asking it to do is look for
commonalities of features amongst the
sufferers that would have it so I don't
think tools like this would be that good
for finding the CNVs because what you're
basically saying it is you're saying oh
look this guy's got it but then it looks
all of the other case and go well more
they haven't got it so we won't roll out
so those are a bit so you had a second
part
yes No
that it wasn't a planning question I'm
glad she asked that I was something I
forget forgot to mention here with this
one because I'm I forgot to mention this
that what when I decided watch of the
mutations fitted into genes because what
Katie mentioned then is she a family
since called eqtls which her expression
quant traitors transitive loci where
they are are regions near the gene so
I'm forgetting the name of it here but
they're regions that are near genes that
affect whether the genes are being
expressed or not and what I've done here
is that I should have mentioned this
that the red one here shows the
mutations that strictly fall within
those regions but when I allow some I
allow some flanking regions upstream and
downstream of the genes I think I've
included these into it now using eqtl
analysis is sort of the neck is things
to start considering for where you can
go with this but then you'd need gene
expression data and then start looking
at so that yes it's it's an interesting
it's an interesting case if they're
definitely worth considering there's - I
think you you're homeless first
right that's a good book I have got the
numbers down somewhere there was there
was still several that I think about
there was about there were 14,000 that
met all of the QC procedures 14,000 in
the of the index snips that made it into
the snip study of which I'd chose the
best 5000 and I think that there are
about 5000 again that were snips that
were actually within these coding
regions and then you could remember that
the some of the genes sets a lot of
those are larger and contain there's a
lot of duplication that goes on within
the genes and the gene sets so snips can
feature in different ones
oh no I see me no I wasn't actually
drilling down because you can have with
the snip with these mutations I didn't
know how to much to go into this but you
can have what's called synonymous or
nonsynonymous mutations where you can
have some where if the if it appears in
a coding region if that happens you'll
actually get a different amino acid part
a chain that goes into the protein that
information just says what I wanted to
do who is really compare it with the
polygenic score analysis which also
doesn't take into account of these
things but you know these are all things
that worth you know doing for future
research yes there's a question
okay
right they're doing there is no effect
of racing this because and how do you
say this in a PC manner the different
effect what they call population
stratification you actually you do have
to only include people from the same
ethnic population that goes into this
and these were Caucasian Brits that went
into this because there are
distributions of different mutations
amongst different populations so if you
were to have for example all of your
cases come from a a Chinese population
and and the controls come from white you
would see amazing significance but of
course you all you'd be measuring you
can actually when you do analysis like
this you can detect differences between
races the gender thing the reason why I
haven't looked in this dataset is there
was a lack of information in it there is
actually an another dataset was far more
people that's just but it's very
recently been genotyped and it's the
last sort of I'm gonna replicate that on
that and I'm gonna look at the see if
there's a gender effect because one idea
is that being female can be slightly
protective against schizophrenia so
would it be the case that females need a
larger sort of genetic risk load to get
the disorder that's what we're going to
consider so that's not going to be the
last push in the last six months we'll
consider that question
absolutely absolutely yes a cognate it's
cognitive disorder how do you need the
behavioral traits
okay come on which water was about that
that sounds interesting so you did have
another question I remember you you were
just going to ask something else
together what sorry they were all said
they were all on the the ones I'm using
here we're on to chips I was an Illumina
chip and an anomaly chip that we use for
that I did initially keep them separate
because I wanted to use one as a test
Acer and also to see whether there would
be any sort of batch effects from the
different chips turns out that I could
use them together that's why I've
combined them what happens when you
talked question is that was answer it
okay yeah it's a bit it is a big thing
that's gonna come in to anything it's
it's all across the whole fit you know
that it comes in to it but because the
thing is with a sorry oh I will get it
this that you know if you have using DNA
is it to predict it you know we
acknowledge that it there are problems
for is that if you have an identical
twin that shares your DNA I think it's
about 50% probability that you're going
to develop the disorder as well that's
the sort of level of risks so even with
the ident even if you've got identical
it's not deterministic amongst those
that have it so it is a very difficult
area
right not on this date set because this
is what the way they get this data for
the for the for the cases is that these
people receive closby and because of the
side effects of this drug can be really
nasty so they they're constantly
monitored for when they're taken and
they constantly give blood samples
it's these anonymized blood samples that
they've agreed to be genotype so we can
take no other other no other information
on these individuals well that's a big
problem is schizophrenia a single
disorder in itself or is it a SPECT it's
a spectrum of disorders it's it's as
fraught with this and so what was the
question you have okay well ultimately
the problem that you have with this is
well the phenotype yeah there's an
assumption that and this was the the the
study that she use these is you know oh
sorry I should have actually mentioned
this was a study that was carried out by
Marian Hampshire that Cardiff University
but I'll put that on the slides when I
when I put them out there but ultimately
the phenotype is they receive clozapine
now it could have been deemed by
psychiatrists to suffer from treatment
resistant schizophrenia so yes it isn't
it is a noisy phenotype unfortunate that
we're dealing with
the reason why I used an SVM was because
I did
I think the SVM has flexibility with how
it builds the decision boundaries I
initially when I started this I would
have liked to have tried the random
forest because you can get the feature
importance that comes out of it but I
think the way that it breaks down and
it's a it makes the dichotomous choice
at a feature if it's above or below this
feature and I think the decision
boundaries if you were to look a random
forest would be more sort of following
our horizontal and vertical lines and I
just found that well when I did that I
was getting receiver operating
characteristics scores around 0.5 so
that's all I did I did consider them but
I just found that this one was was the
most fruitful that I was getting it's
it's something about I normally just
well well initially that's how a lot of
the skit their work in schizophrenia
genetic genetics was carried out they
did what was called linkage analysis so
you would have fewer samples and you'd
say okay we've got affected families
here so what is it about the mother and
the father that's passed on to these
have infected siblings or infected
siblings and those that don't get passed
on to the uninfected siblings and there
was a lot of research done about that
but then what they realized was because
those sort of studies are really good if
you want to find mutations of a large
effect so I think that's how they
discovered Huntington's disease because
you do have this mutation in the
huntingtin proof deer gene that if you
have it you will get you will
unfortunately go on to develop that
disease but the problem with
schizophrenia is that you you need such
large sample sizes to deal with it and
therefore once you then say or how is it
all going to be data now they are
looking at sort of large consortium of
what they call trio data so you have got
mother and father as well as the child
DNA but I'm not too familiar there are
people in the department that work with
this so yes it is being done unfortunate
as phd's go as you further you go along
them they get more and more and more
narrow so you mentally people commit
these all these fantastic things and I
was like yeah I can but I can't I know I
can't do them right now I'm still still
going along okay I think that's well I
think so but then there are people
looking into it so it'll be aware that
it is been done in the field so I'm just
been told parently and you always want
to eat lunch truly you don't